so kanye west put out his album donda
finally
as you know i've been watching kanye
west for several years and since the
album has been out many people have been
asking me
whether i'm going to give some kind of
review of the album and people have been
asking me you know why is kanye west uh
working with marilyn manson and the baby
why is he
you know producing little nas x you know
why is he doing all these things if he's
supposed to be a christian what is going
on you know what is the meaning of some
of his actions and so i want to look a
little bit at uh again at kanye west at
you know let's say his faults his
difficulties and also what it seems that
he
is trying to do and what that means
within a christian context and of course
in his kind of role as this
as this strange fool that is kind of
bridging contradictions let's say we'll
try to look at that and try to make
sense of it a little bit
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
and so when the donda album came out i
have to admit
that in listening to it my first
reaction and i talked about this on the
q a was that the album is all over the
place that it's somehow
is very disparate in terms of sound it
seems very uneven even in terms of
production
and
it seems to be scattered all around and
this of course is compounded by some of
the actions that he's been taking you
know this thing of collaborating with
someone like marilyn manson who is one
of the most anti-christian characters in
music let's say and people like the baby
that has been very controversial
recently on the other side you know
making kind of uh
kind of homophobic comments supposedly i
don't even know what he said but he's
been controversial because of that and
so what is going on and of course you
know getting involved with little nazix
and all of this uh who has put out this
kind of weird satanic inverted video why
is he doing this and so i think that the
first thing we need to understand about
kanye west
and let's say his kind of role in what
he's doing is that from the very
beginning of his career and from the
very very beginning of his
music he is a man of extremes that is
that in his music making you will find
the most radical of extremes you will
find you know these songs about jesus
like on his first album songs that are
about his mother kind of in tribute to
his mother which is not something that
rock stars and rap stars tend to do
but then you'll also find these some of
the most vulgar you know kind of uh
degenerate songs that have ever been
made explicitly very sexually explicit
you know very disturbing and and and uh
and dark and so this is something which
has kind of inhabited him
for a very long time you know he said in
in a long time ago even in his early
songs he would self-identify as catholic
but then also engage in these darker
this dark humor and these very dark
songs and so this is something we need
to understand about him as a person he's
someone who is extremely who kind of
manifests these extremes and has kind of
been living in contradiction
for a very long time
there's a particular song where you
really see this and i remember
there's a song called lost in the world
where he expresses this very clearly in
talking about his wife this is actually
something which came out of a poem that
he wrote for his own wife i don't know
if they were married at the time but
then he wrote for kim kardashian and i
remember hearing interviews about from
kanye
talking about how this is there this
these lyrics are very important to him
these bars and so let me just read you
this part where he talks about
about kim kardashian and he says you're
my devil you're my angel you're my
heaven you're my hell you're my now
you're my forever you're my freedom
you're my jail you're my lies you're my
truth you're my war you're my truce
you're my questions you're my proof
you're my stress and you're my masseuse
and so of course what he's doing is of
course inhabiting
these opposites and showing how his
experience of this woman is
manifesting it's
manifesting itself to him in these
extremes let's say and he does the same
even in this new album in donda uh there
is a uh there's a verse from the from
the video from the song come to life
where he says i get mad when she's gone
mad when she's home mad when she's gone
mad when she's home sad when she's gone
and so this idea that he experiences the
world that's contradiction he
experiences his relationship with with
his wife as contradiction now this is
something that we all experience of
course we all have this experience of
contradiction within ourselves you know
to a certain level but in his
let's say that in his case this seems to
be something which embodies him to the
extreme and which is part of
a little bit of his own madness and a
little bit of his genius as well is to
be able to really perceive these kind of
extreme contradictions in the world now
my
impression or let's say my impression of
what he's trying to do with donda now
that i think about it and now that i
kind of understand
i've been thinking about these
contradictions that he's what he seems
to be trying to do in this album is
trying to pull everything together that
is take all the extremes of his own
music making and pull them into one
place and so a lot of people have been
saying that donda is something like a
like a mix between uh you know his last
album jesus king and jesus which was
this extremely harsh album with very
harsh beats and extremely kind of uh
just this just this really
extreme hardness about it and so on
donna you get these songs that have
these heartbeats and then other songs
which have the using these this kind of
spiritual choir with the organ and this
more kind of uplifting spirit spiritual
uh sense of them but you also have on
this album something which reminds us of
the older albums of kanye which has this
kind of soulful uh more soulful
singy song to them you know like this
this more dance aspect to it as well and
so it seems that he's really trying to
kind of bring it all together into one
place
and um
in that song come to life if you've seen
the uh the video of it you really do get
this imagery in the video itself where
you know in the chicago event where he
played his album for everybody
he had a version of his house in the
middle of the stadium and then at the
top of the house he put an image of the
cross and so he's trying to join the the
notion of the church with the house
which is something that i've done before
and trying to explain people's symbolism
that there's something about the
hierarchy of a house the hierarchy of
intimacy which happens in in the home uh
and this this kind of movement into a
sacred space that you find in
in a church now
in in other videos you'll we'll talk
about it a bit later but out of this
church house comes uh marilyn manson and
the baby with with uh kanye west we'll
talk about that a bit later in this in
the video of come to life you see uh you
see kanye west inside the house
burst on fire
and then you see him walk out of the
house as the house is on fire
and then you see an image of kim
kardashian in this wedding veil kind of
walking down
and you find kanye west coming to him
and then removing his mask like people
don't some people don't know but ever
since it seems like they've announced
their divorce kanye west has hidden his
face basically nobody's seen his face he
just wears this mask uh you know all the
time and so now he is here he is kind of
encountering her and then removing his
mask in front of his bride yeah you know
i mean obviously it's all very strange
because they're supposed to get a
divorce but in terms of symbolism you
can see
can you see the extremes like you have
this sense of the home
church in which which is set ablaze and
then he burns he burns this house down
which i guess is supposed to be some
kind of a baptism but in terms of
extremity you can really see that on the
one hand you have this kind of extreme
image of this house bursting on fire
with him inside and then you have the
joining of him with with his wife where
he removes his his mask and comes face
to face with her you also see him at the
very very end removing her veil and now
kind of joining together and so you have
this extreme of
fire and in the fire he's also wearing a
mask a fire of separation of just this
contradiction and then coming to meet
with his wife and so i think that this
is like an image of what he seems to be
trying to do and in the song come to
life
you really get the ultimate image of
this which is it's a very common image
but if you understand it in the way that
kanye west who he is you get an you get
a very powerful image of this um and so
in this verse where he he said what i
said i'm going to reread it but i'm
going to start from the beginning where
he posits these extremes so he says
don't you wish the night would go numb
i've been feeling low for so long
ain't had a high for so long been in the
dark for so long night is always darkest
before the dawn so notice he's going
from light to dark light to dark light
to dark
gotta make my mark before i'm gone i
don't want to die alone i don't want to
die alone and this is where he goes i
get mad when she's gone man when she's
home mad when she's gone man when she's
home sad when she's gone
then he says floating on a silver lining
yeah you know where to find me riding on
a silver lining
and my god won't deny me tell the devil
get behind me and all the stars are
aligned lift me up every time you know
exactly where to find me which is
riding this silver lining and i think
that this is really one of the most
powerful images of kanye that you can
find which is that he is an image of the
edge he is an image of these extremes
which manifests themselves on the edge
with his obsession with fashion his
obsession with you know with kind of
popular music and also all these
contradictions that i let out for you
but that he is trying to transform this
edge into a silver lining he's trying to
show or find the light in the edge and
trying to make it bright and make it
shine
and in this desire to kind of reconcile
all the opposites i think that this is
exactly what he's doing when he does
things like
reach out to marilyn manson of all
people and include him on his album
reach out to these controversial figures
you know reach out to little nausea and
produce his albums he's he's saying i'm
gonna go to the edge you know he he
seems to think he seems to want that
this notion that the love of christ is
going to kind of reach unto the edge and
he's going to be able to ride the edge
and to turn it into a silver lining now
you might think that this is kind of
silly and extreme but think about the
very album donda
think about what he did
he made an album with just dozens and
dozens of guests of guest features and
chris brown jay-z all of these new
rappers that i don't know anything about
and he made a clean album
he had them on his album without
swearing without talking about
disgusting things without going into the
disgusting subjects that he that these
people usually go into
but he on the contrary he had them all
involved in this cultural project where
by joining themselves with kanye it's
not him who was infected by them but
it's them who were somehow brought into
this kind of new identity that he is
trying to give himself and so this is
something if you want to kind of
understand at least this is my
understanding of what's going on with
kanye now whether he's fully successful
i'm not sure i felt like the donda album
was uneven in many ways uh but
nonetheless i think that this is what he
is trying to accomplish and as usual we
can just continue to watch him to watch
uh to watch you know as he kind of
continues to move in culture to see what
kind of effect he's going to have and he
if he's going to be able to pull all
these threads together and ride that
silver lining so everybody thank you for
your attention and i'll talk to you very
soon
as you know the symbolic world is not
just a bunch of videos on youtube we are
also a podcast which you can find on
your uh usual podcast platform but we
also have a website with a blog and
several very interesting articles by
very intelligent people that have been
thinking about symbolism on all kinds of
subjects we also have a clips channel a
facebook group you know there's a whole
lot of ways that you can get more
involved in the exploration and the
discussion of symbolism don't forget
that my brother matsuya wrote a book
called the language of creation which is
a very powerful synthesis of a lot of
the ideas that explore and so please go
ahead and explore this world you can
also participate by you know buying
things that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and thank you
for your support